eh bien s'il n'est pas là alors je ne sais pas
où il est comme si je nous parlais un gars
paye pour sa chambre d'accord désolé des
informations classifiées pas de coup d'œil par le trou
je me suis récemment marié je cherchais
un endroit pour passer une lune de miel espérait
peut-être pourriez-vous me montrer pourquoi voudriez-
vous passer votre lune de miel ici oh
cet endroit a beaucoup de bons souvenirs
pour moi la toute première fois que j'ai frappé un
homme en godille était ici et c'était un gâchis
mais cette chauve-souris était en aluminium je suis passé à
bois donc tu devrais sortir ton cul ici
tout de suite ou je vais te casser la cervelle partout
sur ce mur avec une [ __ ] de balançoire d'
accord bien sûr que nous partageons le poteau sans douleur sans
gain puccini Mary en septembre